[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
nos encontramos con su excelencia bandak
él es el ministro de industria y
recursos minerales de Arabia Saudita
quien participa en el foro económico
mundial en davos Muchas gracias ministro
por atendernos y le pregunto primero
Cuál es la relación entre Arabia Saudita
y latinoamérica en este momento Y qué
expectativas tienen en el corto plazo
Gracias por la pregunta y gracias por
recibirme como país y especialmente con
su programa visión 2030 Arabia Saudita
quiere tener excelentes relaciones
comerciales con todos los países
actualmente nuestras ambiciones van
mucho más allá de nuestro mercado en
cuanto a la exportación bien sea de
productos terminados o de materia prima
vemos Que América del Sur también puede
aportar muy buenos recursos como
minerales por ejemplo
Argentina países como chile o Argentina
Tienen buena experiencia en minería y
esa experiencia puede ser llevada a
Arabia Saudita para expandir nuestro
sector minero
la semana pasada fue nuestro foro de
minerales del futuro en el que reunimos
a distintos actores en realidad
gobiernos empresas mineras instituciones
financieras y la academia para hablar
sobre el futuro de la Industria
había muchas empresas de América del Sur
y también varios funcionarios del
gobierno incluyendo algunos ministros
y hablamos sobre Cómo construir esa
relación
en la industria también vemos una muy
buena oportunidad
latinoamérica es un buen mercado de
exportación para nosotros para productos
en los que Arabia Saudita está muy
avanzada como los petroquímicos y
productos derivados del petróleo
también vemos una gran oportunidad para
trabajar con América del Sur en áreas
muy importantes de nuestra estrategia
Industrial como el procesamiento de
alimentos productos químicos metales y
demás
siempre estamos buscando socios En
definitiva las relaciones
gubernamentales son importantes Así que
trabajamos con los gobiernos para
asegurar la creación de una una forma
adecuada para que la comunidad
empresarial pueda trabajar y eliminar
cualquier dificultad que pueda surgir
cuando el presidente de Colombia tomó
posesión en agosto del año pasado dijo
que iba a estrechar lazos con Arabia
Saudita Qué significa esto tanto para
este país como para la región
creo que está relacionado también con lo
abierto que está Arabia Saudita a las
relaciones pienso que en el mundo actual
es muy importante edificar la relación
comercial y la relación económica
También estamos agradecidos por esta
iniciativa de dirigirse a los Países
Árabes incluido Arabia Saudita y estoy
seguro de que encontraremos las áreas
adecuadas para poder trabajar juntos
tanto la industria como en la minería
Arabia sauditas bien conocido por los
fondos de inversión que están destinando
recursos a lo largo de todo el planeta
Cuáles son esos países que ustedes están
mirando más de cerca especialmente en la
región de América Latina
esto es más una pregunta para el fondo
soberano el p&f sofred
estoy seguro de que están considerando
varias oportunidades para balancear sus
inversiones
Realmente no estoy al tanto de los
diferentes objetivos pero lo que sé es
que estamos trabajando con el pif para
mejorar algunos de los sectores que
queremos abrir como la industria la
minería la manufactura avanzada la
tecnología y demás
en cuanto a los minerales por ejemplo la
semana pasada el pif creó una empresa
conjunta con madén para invertir en
minería en el extranjero Y asegurar que
tengamos los minerales que necesitamos
en nuestro país para nuestro crecimiento
industrial
El 2022 fue un año atípico para todos
los commodities que expectativas tienen
ustedes en el caso del petróleo y de los
para este año en términos de precios
creo que son dos mercados diferentes
el mercado del petróleo es diferente al
mercado de minerales como comunidad
global realmente pienso que debemos
enfocarnos en la minería y en el
procesamiento de minerales para
asegurarnos detener la cantidad correcta
de estos minerales para nuestra
transición
para los objetivos de cero emisiones
para suministrarle al sector Industrial
los minerales que necesita para los
distintos productos que requieren cada
vez más minerales y metales
ministro Muchas gracias por atendernos
en France 24
gracias de nuevo por recibirme los
invitamos a que sigan este cubrimiento
especial del foro económico mundial aquí
en davos donde tendremos más invitados
en la entrevista de France 24